حركه طالبان تواصل حملتها ضد النساء في
افغانستان لحرمانهن من التعليم والعمل
وزاره الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان خطبت
المنظمات غير الحكوميه الاجنبيه والمحليه
بتعليق توظيف النساء وهددت بالغاء رخص
العمل في حال عدم الامتثال لاوامر الحركه
على المنظمات الاهليه تعليقات توظيف
النساء وفي حاليا عدم الالتزام بالامر
ستلغى رخصه التشغيل الخاصه بالمنظمات
وفي محاوله لتبرير قرار الحركه في منع
توظيف النساء قالت وزاره الاقتصاد ان
الامر يعود لعدم التزامهن بالزي الذي
حددته طالبان
اوامر حركه طالبان الجديده اثار السجالات
ومخاوف من احتمال ان تسري على وكالات
الامم المتحده والمنظمات الانسانيه التي
لها وجود كبير في افغانستان
اعلنت ايضا ان بعض الجامعات ستغلق لمده
اسبوع بسبب احتجاجات بعد الطلاب على منع
التعليم النساء مبرره الامر بعدم جاهزيه
تلك الجامعات وان كانت بعض مقاطع الفيديو
على مواقع التواصل قد اظهرت اطلاق النار
على الطلاب
قرارات حركه طالبان بمنع الطالبات من
الحضور الى الجامعات وعدم اكمال تعليمهن
اثار انتقادات دوليه حاده واحتجاجات ضد
اسرار طالبان على تهنئه دور المراه وتقويض
وجودها بالقوه جاسم محسن العربيه